[Music]
welcome to all of you and I'm very glad
thank you all for coming today to the
first lecture of this fall's lecture
series God and computer Minds machines
and metaphysics I would like to draw
people's attention to the next book to
becoming serious this is the first open
total ten different serious ten
different cognitive scientists and
computer scientists will talk about
their way to address existential
questions women within and outside of
their research we have printed a little
brochure in which you can find the
actual program I heard today that Tech
Talk has actually not quite the LAT
latest version of that serious so this
is the last and ultimate serious
schedule I also would like to draw
people's attention to something we can
also find in that brochure which is a
discussion group a non-credit discussion
group Harvey Cox and me will help at
Harvard Divinity School four times this
fall to give people the opportunity to
discuss questions which come up here in
the series and different talks and where
they don't have the opportunity to
address them within the talk within the
forum on Wednesday evenings and it is
now my pleasure to introduce our speaker
for today
professor Paul Penfield is currently
head of the department of electrical
engineering and computer science here at
MIT which is by far the biggest
department here at MIT and Paul has held
this position since 1989 but at MIT
itself he has been far longer than that
he got his doctorate his doctorate of
Science here in 1960 and entered
afterwards of the faculty and today he
is a member of the National Academy of
Engineering and was also president of
the National Electrical Engineering
Department says Association in addition
to numerous other awards he received the
Darlington award and the Centennial
medal of the Institute of Electrical and
Electronic Engineering
Paul has widely published technical
issues but also increasingly about
questions on pedagogy and problems in
computer science and electrical
engineering education in his time as
head the electrical engineering and
computer science department introduced a
special bachelor program in which
students after five years receive a
master of engineering degree
Paul has impressed me since I came here
with his humor and also with his genuine
interest for students it is apparent
that he cares greatly about graduating
students who are unsurpassed engineers
and computer scientists and yet who have
also a strong sense of responsibility as
individuals and in their role in society
and is therefore my great pleasure to
have you tonight here and you share your
thoughts with us on God the scientists
well thank you Anne
I was wondering actually I don't know
that we need the house lights down all
that much thank you why let there be
light
isn't that a little response I didn't
know whether n was talking about me or
someone else but but I am honored to be
able to invite be invited Thank You Anne
to give this first lecture series on
Godin computers and it is being held in
conjunction with an MIT EECS course
which Anne is offering to students this
fall what I hope to do is to say a few
things about the effectiveness with
which God is invoked as a way of
explaining things that's my title God's
a scientist but I have to start with a
disclaimer I'm I'm not educated in
philosophy or religion as I hope you
could tell from Anne's introduction I
really know nothing about God I have
somebody thinks that's funny
I have no particular religious training
and I regard myself more as a scientist
or an engineer than I do as a devout
person nevertheless I am active in the
mainline Protestant Christian Church in
the town where I live and I come from a
family in which my grandfather and uncle
were both Presbyterian ministers and one
of my cousin's today is a UCC minister
their love of God and things religious
though never did rub off on me
as much as it did on other members of my
family but one thing that did rub off on
me was my family's love of good times
and singing picture me if you can at the
age of 10 was my family sitting around
the campfire after dinner somebody
breaks out a guitar and we all sing
along one old favorite that was sure to
be sung with much a mature harmonizing
is called tell me why
[Music]
this is a song that many of you perhaps
have sung it's a it's got a bunch of
good questions why do the stars shine
why is the sky blue one answer to these
questions is contained in the second
verse to the song say I got got in here
somewhere
[Music]
this is what might be considered the
romantic answer to those questions it
appealed to my teenage sisters at the
time perhaps it still does to their
grandchildren I'm not sure
however we small boys in the family
sometimes came back with an alternate
verse which might be considered of a the
smart aleck answer to these same
questions
[Music]
whatever you may think of the way that
this verse destroys the peaceful
campfire mood at least at least it does
offer answers to these questions and
answers that are sort of based in
science rather than on God why do the
stars shine is it because of nuclear
fusion as astrophysicists and little
boys would tell you or is it because God
made them to shine or might both
explanations be valid and perhaps useful
in different circumstances this is a
caricature of the kind of question that
I want to try to address today it's a
small example perhaps a trivial one of
our tendency to invoke God to explain
what he we humans may not understand
we're appealing therefore to God the
scientist and this is how I got the
title for this talk so the question is
is God a good scientist how would the
answer because God made the Ivy twine
how would that stack up as a scientific
explanation well let me explain that in
science explanations are provided by
theories I'll have to say a few things
about how scientists go about
distinguishing good theories from bad
theories partly because many non
scientists and I gather there are some
non scientists in the audience here may
not appreciate what a scientific theory
really is for example some people if you
know a scientist you might ask him or
her
do you believe Einstein's theory of
relativity that do you believe in signs
theory of relativity or another question
our Newton's laws true you know our
Newton's laws true the word true and
believe are what I'm getting at to a
scientist these questions are really not
appropriate they're not appropriate
kinds of questions and I'd like to
explain that as a way of of going on to
a scientist a scientific theory is
really nothing more than a working
hypothesis one that's consistent it's
consistent with what the
available evidence a scientist may use a
theory compare its predictions with
observations but the concept of
believing a theory the way a religious
person may believe in God is not
necessary and if it's not necessary it's
not done in science a scientist or
engineer might have an opinion about how
useful or how accurate a theory is but a
theory after all is just a tool if it
works in your circumstances fine if not
get a better tool a hammer is a tool you
don't believe in a hammer
you use it when you think it does the
job now another common misconception is
that a scientific theory is either true
or false remember the questions are
Newton's laws true or are they valid the
misconception is that the scientific
theory is either true or false and that
a single experiment can invalidate that
theory however a scientist would not go
along with that a scientist would only
say whether a theory is accurate enough
for the purposes at hand it's not a
matter of being right or wrong for
example Newton's laws of motion as
usually formulated fail when the motion
is very high-speed because of effects of
special relativity this does not mean
that Newton's laws are wrong what it
means is that there are approximate they
have their own domain over which they're
very effective and can be used all
theories and laws in science are
approximate the important question to a
scientist is not whether the law is
valid or not but whether it's good
enough for the purpose at hand now don't
get me wrong I'm not saying that all
scientific theories are good and I'm not
saying saying that some of them are
wrong I'm saying that some are good but
some are bad scientists and engineers
and others who use science in their work
do judge theories and render judgments
about how goodness
and the scientific community is going to
reject bad theories by simply not using
them and there's another point that has
to be made for the benefit of the non
scientists in the audience you may not
appreciate that there can be and usually
is more than one theory for a scientist
or engineer to choose from we're sort of
a free enterprise competition among
theories those that are used are those
that are deemed most useful for example
in mechanic's a scientist would have at
least three different theories which
could be used to predict the motion of
electrons or other objects
there's Newton's second law which is
usually used in cases where speed is not
approaching the speed of light it's very
accurate and every day you stand it's
very simple
Einstein's special theory of relativity
is useful then when the coordinate
systems are in what's called an inertial
frame and Einstein's general theory of
relativity is useful when there are
accelerated frames and gravity present
these each of these is successively more
complex and yet successively covers a
wider domain so somebody who is who
wants to do something in mechanic's
would have at least these three theories
to work with now think for a moment
about the campfire song that we just
heard there seem to be two proposed
theories about why the sky is blue one
of them Rayleigh diffraction the other
because God made it blue this is not
unlike the case of mechanics a scientist
is faced with the need to explain the
color of the sky can choose from those
two theories just as another scientist
calculating the motion of an electron
might choose from among these three
theories so how does the scientist tell
a good theory from a bad one and I'm
going to tell you what I believe are the
three most important metrics by which
scientists judge theories to see
they're any good or not a good
scientific theory is one that is
accurate simple and suggestive and I'll
explain what I mean by each of these
attributes accurate a good theory should
allow any scientist to predict the
results of experiments not yet performed
or observations not yet made with a
reasonable degree of accuracy over a
reasonable range of conditions
reasonable domain the larger its range
of validity and the more accurate the
predictions the better for example since
Einstein's theory of general relativity
can describe systems undergoing
acceleration it is more accurate than
the special theory of relativity okay
one aspect of accuracy that we have to
point out is the ability of a good
theory to work from first principles
without the need of ad hoc assumptions
or the need to estimate missing
parameters this feature of completeness
while it's desirable is really not all
that common many scientific theories
involve parameters such as a
gravitational constant which have to be
measured experimentally it cannot be
predicted from first principles well the
theory which does not involve such
missing parameters is going to be deemed
better by scientists simple obviously a
good theory should be based on concepts
which are itself simpler than the
phenomenon that you're talking about it
should be easy to use easy to teach easy
to explain to others it should not
require extensive computation by this
measure the theory of general relativity
is bottom one gets low Marx theory of
general relativity gets low marks
because it uses curvilinear coordinate
systems which are very difficult to work
with
suggestive this is something that
scientists don't always think about but
a good theory should lead a perceptive
scientist to think of interesting new
experiments or extensions to the theory
connections to other theories
explanations of other phenomenon not
originally considered for example the
general theory of relativity
despite its its complexity the general
theory of relativity predicted the
existence of gravitational waves and now
scientists are busy trying to find them
they haven't found them yet and the
special theory of relativity suggested
the equivalence of mass and energy
through one of its one of the branches
from it and that of course was
discovered and forms the foundation for
atomic energy so these are the three
attributes that a good scientific theory
has it's accurate it's simple and it's
suggestive so was this as a background
let's go back to the campfire song and
ask how God the scientist is doing the
theory because God made the sky so blue
this is a scientific theory it purports
to explain why skies blue because God
made the sky so blue now that gets low
marks on accuracy think about it
sometimes the sky is blue but sometimes
it's not this theory does not account
for clouds it does not account for
observations made in outer space on the
other hand Rayleigh diffraction which I
should explain Rayleigh diffraction is
the tendency of blue light to bend as it
comes through the atmosphere more than
red light does all light bends somewhat
coming through the atmosphere but blue
light bends more and that tendency is is
what really diffraction predicts that
provides a more accurate explanation for
example it doesn't fall into the trap of
predicting that the sky is going to be
blue at night and the explanation
because God made the sky so blue you
at nighttime what do you expect you
expect a blue sky well so God the
scientist is not doing too well on
accuracy now what about simplicity it's
true that the statement because God made
the sky so blue is itself very simple
there's no question about that
but the theory is not itself based on
simple concepts let me point out it
seems that in doing so God had to make
certain choices for example why didn't
God make the sky green well really
diffraction would answer that question
but because God made the sky so blue
makes you wondering why not green either
the color of the sky is an arbitrary
choice made by God or it's related to
some property of God which hasn't been
explained yet or it's an unpredicted
parameter of the theory a missing
parameter anyway God the scientist is in
trouble with this explanation if God has
some property that sets the sky color it
must be one of thousands of such
properties and what are we to make of
any concept which has thousands of of
seemingly ad-hoc or arbitrary choices
connected with it any model of God with
so many ad hoc properties must be
extremely complex alternatively if the
sky color is an unpredicted parameter
then the theory really fails to explain
anything because if you ask what color's
the sky and say it's unpredicted you
have to measure it it doesn't doesn't do
very well so there's a problem there now
how about suggestiveness Rayleigh
diffraction really is a good explanation
of why the sky is blue it not only
explains why the sky is blue but think
about it it explains why a sunset is red
for the very same reason because all the
well as as the light comes in the blue
sky gets gets bent more and the red sky
goes and continues to the place where
people are observing sunrises and
sunsets
on the other hand invoking God in this
context is not really explaining
anything at all
we have to come down and say that it's
just a way of closing off discussion or
saying that the explanation is really so
arcane that it's not worthwhile to
pursue it and this I submit is the
opposite of opening up new questions so
it seems that God the scientist isn't
doing too well in the explaining why the
sky is blue of course in God's defense
it has to be said that the campfire song
really has nothing to do about science
the romantic mood is in fact intense
rather well by using God to avoid any
scientific explanations and besides
aren't we stretching a point too far
surely nobody would ever try to use God
to explain why the stars to shine or
what they the campfire song asks
relatively simple perhaps trivial
questions but there are other deeper
questions that science has not yet
solved and God is often called upon to
explain those let me mention three of
these first one is the creation how was
how did the world start second one what
is life and what is cognition cognition
is very germane to the to the topic of
this whole series because in a sense
understanding cognition is the holy
grail of artificial intelligence so let
me mention these three
although physicists have some pretty
good theories about the Big Bang there's
still only speculation about what might
have been there before on the other hand
there are many religious myths about the
creation in my own judeo-christian
tradition we learn in Genesis that God
has God created the world in six days
was explained to me when I was in high
school but that was because God was a
good Jew and Jews observed six days and
then had the Sabbath and
theory was that God was created in man's
image rather than the other way around
well I don't want to necessarily take
sides on that Christian fundamentalists
on the other hand accept literally as a
matter of faith this biblical
explanation many of them will even tell
you when it happened
sometime within the past ten thousand
years five thousand some number of years
and they might also quote Genesis 1:16
notice the last line what were we saying
about nobody seriously using God to
explain why the stars do shine in fact
Christian fundamentalists would say that
that's what exactly what they do now let
me go on life is the second of those
deeper questions biologists are now
beginning to understand the physical and
chemical processes that go on in
biological systems gradually the theory
of evolution is being flushed out with
more details
experimental evidence is accumulating
one of the most interesting of these
happen last May there was a report of
some very rapid adaptation of a species
of lizard on the Caribbean island it
seems that within fifteen years after
introduction to an island that had
smaller branches for these lizards to
perch on within 15 years the lizards
that were growing up in those islands
was just only a few generations those
lizards were found to have slightly
shorter legs this effect had been
predicted before the experiment was done
these lizards were actually transported
Tooley to the new island a series of
eleven or twelve islands actually and a
prediction was made and the correlation
between the size of the branches
available for the lizards to perch on
and the length of the legs was quite
striking and this was in only fifteen
years the effect had been predicted it's
not clear whether that
adaptation was genetic or not and this
is one of the open questions about that
particular experiment now
fundamentalists will scoff at the theory
of evolution saying that it's only a
theory
in fact I've personally heard that very
statement it's only a theory well of
course it is
yes most scientists would agree it is a
theory but then they would point out
that it's a better theory than
creationism when judged in terms of its
accuracy simplicity and suggestiveness
and these are the criteria that
scientists cherish now let me go to the
third of those deep questions cognition
this question seems to be a very
difficult one for science the the object
of the study can be can be phrased in
many different ways
one of them is to imitate nature by
building a machine that seems human
another way of doing it is to understand
how and why the mind differs from the
brain another way of explaining it is to
say that science would like to
understand what the soul is so far the
best efforts of biologists
neurophysiologists computer scientists
philosophers and others have not really
led to any success computers for sure
have been able to beat humans at some
games such as tic-tac-toe or even chess
for that matter but to my knowledge the
Turing test has never been met those for
those of you who don't know what the
Turing test is this is a test of machine
intelligence it was defined by the late
Alan Turing who was one of the legendary
computers science pioneers in this test
a person sits and ask questions and
tries to tell whether the answers that
come back come from another person or
come from a computer a computer that is
good enough to be able to trick people
into thinking it's human will pass the
test and so far that has never happened
maybe it will someday but it hasn't yet
so cognition is the case where science
really is has made what I would say is
very little progress
on the heart of the problem so here we
have some examples where science has
something to offer and examples where
science does not and among the questions
for which the tools of science don't
seem to work and remember that's the
important thing do they work or not not
are they true but do they work among the
questions for which the tools of science
don't work I think it is useful to
identify three different categories the
first category is doesn't work now but
it's only a matter of time and everybody
believes that sooner or later science
will crack that problem there are plenty
of examples like that the second
category I would have is a category of
scientific theory in which science will
never work and it can be proven that it
will never work for them demonstra Bowl
reasons and the third category of course
are those in between where reasonable
people can differ from each other as to
whether or not science will ever work
and I'll have examples of the last two
first how about an example in which
science will never work and my friends
and the audience who are concerned with
computer complexity will jump for joy at
this one consider a gas such as air
there's already a fairly good theory
about the behavior of a gas and the
scale of a few millimeters up this is a
so-called macroscopic scale concepts
such as pressure velocity temperature
density and so on are used in most
theories we know how to design airplane
wings and we know that we can predict
with good accuracy how gases flow around
various kinds of obstacles the
macroscopic Theory works to be sure it
has a bunch of of missing parameters but
once those are measured it's a it's a
reasonably good theory
but there's also a microscopic picture
and think of little gas molecules
bouncing against each other their little
little particles bouncing around hitting
each other one theory which would be
useful and which will never happen is to
predict through simulation of the
microscopic molecules what the
macroscopic motion is and thereby to
deduce the properties of gases now think
of it you have a little container that
has maybe a lot of gas molecules in it
if you know each gas molecules position
you know each gas molecules direction
the velocity the property of each one
you ought to be able to calculate what
the configuration is anytime in the
future and therefore you could predict
the results of experiments that were
conceived of at the macroscopic scale
there was a finite number of molecules
and so why don't we just go ahead and
calculate it simulation which is what
this is is a very effective scientific
and engineering tool used all the time
and it would be extremely useful if it
would work in this case let me explain
several reasons why it won't first think
of the number of molecules in question
this number is approximately what's
known as avocados number which you may
remember from your high school chemistry
that's the number of molecules in a mole
of any chemical substance and it's
really a pretty big number it's about 6
times 10 raised to the 23rd power this
is really an enormous number much larger
than any number which is encountered in
everyday life and I tried to think of a
way in which the size of that number
could be explained to the audience and
try this consider the best laser printer
which you can buy for your personal
computer laser printer puts little dots
on a sheet and if the dots are small
enough it looks like continuous writing
and these are very successful products
and the best laser printers that you can
buy have a resolution of about 600 dots
per
that is in any inch he gets 600 and then
square inch you get 600 times 600 such
dots on a single piece of paper there
could be 30 million separate dots now 30
million is a pretty large number but
it's a lot less than Avogadro's number
now think of the whole surface of the
earth all the land and all the oceans
all covered with dots of this size and
the number of dots that you get just 600
dots per inch would be about Avogadro's
number covering the whole surface of the
earth and that's such a large number
that it's impossible to to really
conceive of in everyday terms now
consider the practical problem of
calculating with this many particles
suppose each air molecule is
characterized by its position its
velocity its orientation and its angular
velocity then any computer that simply
looks at the data for all the molecules
without even doing any calculations but
just looks at the data it would take a
long time to do that in fact if you did
that on a very fast modern computer at
the rate of 50 million of these per
second it would take about five billion
years now for those of you who don't
recognize large numbers five billion
years is the age of the earth so if you
wanted just to read all the data about
this system it would take the estimated
age of the earth just to do that without
even doing any calculations the
conclusion from all this is that a
detailed microscopic simulation is
impractical because of a large number of
molecules that are involved
remember the criterion that a good
scientific theory has to be simple and
easy to apply this one really fails
big-time the most that can be done from
a microscopic simulation is to predict
the general nature of a few macroscopic
variables and such simulation doesn't
even do that very well
we cannot predict any detailed motion
now it's interesting to note that there
are other reasons why this approach will
never work either one of them is the
huge size of the computer memory needed
to store the data
another is the impossibility of
measuring simultaneously the position
and velocity of small particles which
comes from the so-called Heisenberg
uncertainty principle but we ought to be
able to get around that by using quantum
mechanics instead of Newton's laws and
another one has to do with the extreme
sensitivity of the calculations to very
small changes in the assumed initial
conditions the initial velocities and
positions this is what's known as the
chaotic system
term chaotic maybe gives the wrong
connotation but systems in science where
there's an extraordinarily what's called
exponential dependence on the initial
conditions was known as chaotic and this
is one of them this means that it's
almost impossible for practical reasons
to do microscopic simulation so what is
this example imply about science what it
says is that different areas of science
may be separated by a gap that cannot be
breached even using the fastest
computers imaginable different
approaches different variables different
styles different theories are needed you
know fluid dynamics the macroscopic is
really different from any molecular
theory that you can imagine it uses a
different approach different styles in a
similar but less extreme way chemistry
is different from physics even though
chemical systems surely obey all the
basic laws of physics and biology is
different from chemistry and different
from biology even though biological
systems have to obey all the laws of
chemistry and physics along the way and
I will argue in a minute
the mind is different from the brain in
a similar way so let me come to the
third open question which is cognition
and I'm going to assert the cognition I
just gave an example
of this category I'm going to assert the
cognition there's a difference of
opinion as to whether cognition will
ever be cracked by science or not one
way of understanding the thinking
process might be to perform simulation
based on a model of the brain now a
model of the brain doesn't have to use
10 to the 23rd elements what does it
need to do well the brain has about a
trillion neurons that's ten to the
twelfth the last time I checked each of
them is connected to a thousand other
neurons on average so simulation using a
neural model requires consideration of a
trillion neurons and a trillion times a
thousand other connections and this is
getting to be a pretty large number even
for modern computers simulation using
the neural model is not going to work
because of a large number of neurons a
complexity of the models for each neuron
the number of connections among the
neurons the sensitivity of the
calculated results to the details of the
initial conditions and of course the
speed of even the fastest computers that
are likely to be available the most we
can hope for from neural simulation is
the identification of a few averages
like in fluid flow like the pressure and
density to explain cognition though
it'll be necessary to deal with many
more cognitive quantities than you deal
with in fluid mechanics for example
you'd have to predict at least as many
results as a typical and how many
thoughts or feelings does an individual
have you'd have to make at least that
many predictions from any simulated
theory
so I assert that neural simulation will
not work what about other approaches
well the mission of computer science at
the end of the day when all of a sudden
done
is to manage complexity all the things
that computer scientists do in one way
or another are limited by complexity of
the of the artifacts that they deal with
if cognition is also complex perhaps the
tools of computer science can help now I
may be wrong but I tend to be
pessimistic about this approach so far
there is really very little evidence
that the architecture of a brain is
similar in any deep way to the
architecture of a computer without some
degree of fundamental similarity isert
there's no reason to suppose that the
underlying concepts would be the same
and that the tools and computer science
would work in my opinion a more likely
outcome of study of this and a very
useful one would be to create new
computer architectures that mimic the
brain that's much more likely and would
be much it would be very useful now
there is a field that's received a lot
of attention recently so I should say
something about it
it goes under the name neural networks
the structure of a neural network is
motivated by the assumed structure of
the brain with its interconnected
neurons there is at this point to my
understanding no general theory of how
such systems work from a theoretical
point of view but they have been made to
do useful engineering tasks but as far
as I know there hasn't been any helpful
insights from these activities that have
been applied back to help formulate a
theory of cognition I would be happy to
be informed otherwise I'm not aware of
any so we've seen some approaches which
don't seem to offer much promise are
there other approaches that will work
I served there's no clear evidence one
way or another this is a debatable case
a lot of people have put a lot of effort
into working on this without success and
I'll tell you what my opinion is here
and this will not be the opinion that
by everyone in this room my opinion is
that there will never be a good
scientific theory that explains
cognition a theory that like other good
scientific theories is accurate
simple and suggestive remember a theory
that stands up to judgment and criticism
of scientists now I'm not trying to
denigrate research in this field on the
contrary some progress has been and will
be made in this area there'll be lots of
results obtained along the way which
will be very useful for example in
guiding the design of man-made systems
such as computers robots and so on but
in my opinion and this is debatable and
therefore other people can have other
opinions the lofty goal of explaining
cognition scientifically will not be
achieved now if we accept that assertion
or even if we don't accept that
assertion for for that matter and if we
only say that cognition is not yet
understood you know the people who
believe that it will someday be
understood are in this category
if cognition is not currently understood
and I say it never will be understood by
science some things are therefore
excluded from the realm of science and
those are things that are naturally
related to self-awareness things that
are felt internally personally and I'm
going to Lumpy's together under the name
human nature although that isn't quite
the right concept I think it's pretty
close these include thoughts aesthetics
desires feelings emotions like love
grief jealousy hatred intellectual
capabilities like instinct judgment
intuition intelligence these will not be
adequately explained by any scientific
theory
so what alternative do we have if we
need to reason about one of these topics
or for that matter about any of a number
of other topics that are not now
understood by science if we need to
reason about them it'll have to be done
by non-scientific means one such
approach is to make assumptions that are
not justified by science and then to
proceed these assumptions are sometimes
called leaps of faith and science in
general tries to avoid such assumptions
whereas most religions and many other
human activities seem to require them
but of course faith is an intensely
personal matter what one person the same
assumes will generally differ from what
another assumes and science by its very
nature produces results that are
supposed to be able to be reproduced by
others so the leaps of faith are
inherently non-scientific I want to call
this approach faith based reasoning
whether or not the concept of God or
religious concepts are involved
assumptions that are not justified
scientifically I want to call faith
based reasoning faith based reasoning
inevitably lacks the scientific criteria
of accuracy simplicity and
suggestiveness it's tempting to say that
it's therefore bad science well maybe it
is but maybe it's the best we have and
maybe if we keep in mind the underlying
assumptions keep in mind the leaps of
faith that are made at the beginning of
the analysis maybe we can still have
some reasonably useful theories lots of
people we all admire artists architects
doctors managers musicians social
scientists and engineers for that matter
rely in part on science and in part on
understanding of human nature and social
systems and if as
sir human nature cannot be understood by
science and if we get too smug about
discounting anything non-scientific we
may be left with no tools at all to work
with another point we scientists and
engineers should not forget that science
as an endeavor is itself based on a set
of assumptions we use mathematics logic
deductive reasoning and a host of other
tools that in the final analysis are not
themselves provable by any rational
means we all assume that the behavior of
nature is not changing with time how can
we be sure when you really get down to
it we use all these assumptions
underlying science for what is really a
very simple pragmatic reason and that is
that they work why shouldn't we be
prepared to be equally pragmatic in
considering in considering whether to
use faith based reasoning the important
question is does it work now there is
another reason we should not look down
upon non-scientific reasoning too much
science itself is a human activity we
scientists are ourselves humans after
all we have our own personal thoughts
hopes dreams feelings and emotions nicer
that those cannot be explained by
science from time to time we all pursue
activities that are not based on
rational thought I'm sure sometimes when
doing science but at least off-the-job
enjoying fine music or beautiful art
even though there's no scientific
explanation of aesthetics even on the
job science deals with artifacts and
theories that scientists themselves
considered to be things of beauty so the
aesthetics even as applied in the
judgment of scientific theories
themselves
as for another example let's consider
the motion of grief many of us in this
room know what it's like to experience
grief resulting from the death of a
close friend or a relative right now the
entire MIT community is going through a
period of grief over the tragic loss of
a freshman
Scott Kruger to alcohol poisoning a few
days ago now this emotion of grief is a
very real one someday science may have
something to say about the neural
patterns associated with grief science
may even develop a specific mood
changing drug that inhibits those
patterns in some ways however isert the
grief also has a deeper emotional side
to it and if you need to cope with this
aspect of grief you might find helpful
support in societal mechanisms including
religious ones many people have found
that a faith based on a belief in God is
effective in providing solace and
comfort not many people would receive
much consolation from knowing that their
grief is somehow related to chemical
imbalances in the brain or our patterns
of firing of neurons in other words in
handling grief science doesn't help but
a belief in God does let's be pragmatic
if it works that's the important
question as for another emotion love I
sincerely hope that everyone in this
room has or will experience the joy that
a company's total unconstrained love for
another human being it's a wonderful
thing it may be true that sex the
physical side of love is somehow
explained by chemical hormones as a
smart-aleck verse of a campfire song
says chemical hormones that's why I love
you but I assert it surely true that the
deeper emotional and spiritual aspects
and ultimately of a more satisfying and
pleasurable ones are better described by
a romantic and
sir such as because God made you that's
why I love you and I'd like to wish for
everyone in this room a chance to say to
your loved one
something like what to tell you loved on
chemical hormones that's why I love you
or wouldn't your brother say to your
loved one something like because God
made you that's why I love you
thank you for your attention
we have 20 minutes time for questions
Thank You Paulette well wonderful talk
thank you we have 20 minutes time for
questions so are there any questions
comments or well that's my opinion
other people do and I was careful to say
that that's in that third category well
it's true that that's an opinion and
therefore it's not subject to the same
kind of scientific analysis that I would
like to apply to calculate the
trajectory of electrons that is true I'm
basing it on the following observations
that a lot of very smart people have
worked for a long time and made very
little progress computer science has has
this open question called
is P equal to non P it equal to NP there
are there are certain problems in
computer science that can in principle
be solved by running a computer in a
time which is known as polynomial time
that is not too fast and there are other
ones for which nobody has yet discovered
a procedure or an algorithm that works
that way it's never been proven I think
most every computer scientist if you ask
them is P equal to NP that is is it
possible eventually to find a polynomial
polynomial time solution would say no
but it's never been proved and the
reason they would say no is that a lot
of very smart people have worked a long
time and never made any progress at all
really on that now some of my colleagues
are going to differ with me but I think
that most of the computer science tiered
approach would express an opinion that P
is not equal to NP now I'm a
forcing an opinion that's based on the
same kind of evidence and I would be
happy to listen other people who have
can explain why they have a different
opinion if you come back in three weeks
Rodney Brooks will talk about official
humanity that is exactly that's right
and has done a marvelous job of getting
people with different fundamental
beliefs here and I will have the wind
knocked out of my sails completely by
Rod Brooks who knows much more about the
subject do you want to handle a
questioner okay crosstalk no be sure you
speak loud enough so that everybody in
the back in here I don't know what means
to know as a scientist I will take a
tool and use it where it's appropriate
as a carpenter I will use a hammer or
screwdriver and I know when to use what
tool and I've learned what tools work
what does it mean to know
Paulette you know I like it all the way
up to a certain point and then you took
a leap that I think leaves a lot which
is you know you've split it into this
menu got three plus five Monday choice
as to whether we have a scientific
theory by which I to you you mean a
scientific theory like physics yeah okay
the on the other side you have
things like faith in God and there's
this huge middle that I think is an
enormous really rich part of human
experience including all the social
sciences which have theories which
although not tested in the same way or
coming up to the same level of in some
sense abstract scientific perfection as
say physics nevertheless are very useful
theories and yet still are not based on
on faith in the faith in say God or
religious values and yet which still are
various from there's a whole range what
are you gonna start disagreeing with me
so what I'm saying is wise you posit is
this choice between those two things
oh yeah when you skipped over this whole
huge middle thing which may be an even
more adequate explanation for the
various things that you've described
here Oh Charles what what remember what
I did I said when when you when you
don't have a good scientific theory you
have to make some assumptions and I
called him a leap of faith and that
doesn't necessarily involve religion
doesn't necessarily involve God doesn't
necessarily involve but it does mean an
assumption but if you can keep a number
of assumptions small you can have a
better structure that's built on it
maybe the social scientists do that
reasonably well there certainly is a big
middle ground and it isn't as so you
have on the one extreme the the
scientists who don't have any
assumptions in fact I tried to to say
that science is itself built upon
unprovable assertions and on the other
side religion I don't think it's a it's
like at all I fully agree with you
in the middle but the thing is that when
you start believing there is some
unknowable entity structure you don't
even then well you may call sloppy
thinking but come back to the point
where I was trying to make in coping
with grief as a specific thing if your
wife dies or if your mother dies or
something like that you surely have an
emotion there's no question about that
what do you do about it I assert that
that's an area where sloppy thinking as
you call it has in fact over the years
and over the centuries provided help so
be pragmatic is it going to help you or
not
so but will you start asserting its
objective and anesthetist and gets wrong
and that's what people say well I didn't
say that I didn't say that maybe some
people do well I think science may
someday associate specific neural firing
patterns and this sort of thing may talk
something about the the biochemistry of
a brain one that's undergoing grief I
think there's a lot of opportunity to
discover things that are not currently
known what you're saying is that my
illustration about how to handle grief
is not so much science as it is
engineering and I got to admit I'm more
of an engineer than a scientist rather
than understand in some sense whatever
that means
I want to build and provide solutions to
problems and being presented with grief
I maintain is a problem that if I can
find the solution for it then I've
served as as a good engineer and so
you're quite right that it isn't so much
the my example doesn't so much point to
science as it does to providing
solutions for human problems which is
what engineers do
mine does it and trying to mimic it we
just did it and so my question is even
if we grant machines were brute force
also know things at work get forward
their father be brute force and end up
being more clever I guess my question is
even if we never have a theory that
explains how it is or why it is that
people do what they do why is there any
reason to think that we won't be able to
engineer a system that can think as well
or feel as deeply or be a self-aware or
even more so than people are well this
is a this is a theme that I've heard
before and it's an important one do we
have to imitate the structure of nature
in order to get the same function of
nature as a way of phrasing that
question do we have to actually
understand in some sense the all the
relationships in the brain in order to
make something that will behave as a
brain and you're asserting that we
probably do not that would agree with
that
if you won't have been a fast computer
you should not be mimicking the brain
because it would be half of the brain
already you want to do something better
no worse or rather no better than a
mostly worse than that if I had if I had
a well worked out solution to something
and I wanted to do do something better I
take a different approach and maybe
that's what we should do nevertheless I
assert that there are a lot of domains
in which the attributes that a brain has
slow but able to deal with ambiguity and
a lot of things like that would be very
useful in engineered objects and
therefore having one which had some of
the architecture of a brain might be
useful
and then you yes no I'm maybe yeah you
want to check well gee it's practically
probably appropriate to consider them
possibly an old one of these I'd like to
say met a point you are they extremely
bad ever moved something from the
debatable into the unknowable by your
belief yeah the reason for that is
because inhibits the investigation of
such a thing which might turn out to be
no always worried man even in purity
almost hopeless situation than what
their mathematical proof is always more
advantage to apply effort against the
things that are currently debating I
think there's a lot of truth in what you
say nevertheless my charge from an was
to give a personal view and I gave a
personal view I am pessimistic about
that particular line of research
accomplishing that grand objective now
it can accomplish a lot of other things
you're saying that it's
counterproductive for people to say that
too loudly because you'll destroy the
motivation of a lot of people even to
themselves okay there's some there's
some truth to that
the question is how much promise comes
from quantum mechanics or quantum theory
in answering some of the questions and I
don't believe that like quantum
mechanics has any improvements over I
don't think that it has anything to
offer that hasn't already been talked
about here I don't think that that
particulars there there is one example
that I cited in the molecular simulation
of a gas where there is a a the
theoretical impossibility of measuring
accurately enough both position and
velocity and what you have to do is
choose new coordinates that don't have
that problem you have to take into
account quantum mechanics and so you can
probably get around that but that still
doesn't make the problem solvable
where you have a face and scientifically
based theory and I'm curious why isn't
it that it is just two coordinate
systems and Iraqis that there is a
superset basically a face and as we get
better at the complex analyses as our
computers get bigger that we eat away at
the universal set of faith days or is it
that you know there is a faith base in
both the simple and the complex for
example maybe God made rollies of
diffusion you know well let me let me
try to attack that in the following
point of view some people that I've
talked to about this assert that you
start off knowing nothing and therefore
everything has to be because God made I
mean there was a time when when God was
used to invoke how the tides worked and
all sorts of things okay and then
gradually science chips away at that
eats around the edges and grabs portions
that can be you can use scientific
method to make predictions that are more
accurate simpler and so on so it's
better science and some people have the
model that there's this this wall that
is gradually being encroached upon now
that's not my view my view is closer to
the one which charles leiserson came up
with a few minutes ago which is there
are a large number of endeavors in which
some combination of reasonable
assumptions that that can be justified
and assumptions that cannot be justified
are mixed together in some way in a way
that's been found practical and useful
and I tend to believe that that's more
of the case and that it's a lot more
complex than the simple wall between the
known and the unknown
the limits of your pragmatism when
dealing with things like breathing well
I would assert that astrology has
overtly one of its objectives is the
same as science to make predictions you
pick up the morning newspaper and you
read your horoscope that you will you'll
come into a bundle of mundane the money
in the next week or something like that
so that as an endeavor is attempting to
do the same sort of thing that science
does now is it as effective I believe
that most people would argue that it's
not as effective it's got a poor track
record of accuracy and it's got hidden
assumptions all over the place so in
that sense it would be bad science now
if your grief is in fact relieved by
astrology I don't know what I don't know
what to say I I doubt that that would be
true for very many people I think it is
true for a larger number of people that
organized religion does provide ways of
handling things like that we have to
stop here unfortunately we could say
okay the audience wants to stand that I
can stand it I'm thinking more about
these
why the skies blue and one was for the
other one we're scattering and my
question is well I I my question is that
really if scattering really explains why
the blue the sky is blue because if you
say okay scatter explain it but what is
the scattering how may be scattering and
make kind of the stripe like how things
happen and sometimes this plane is
better than others and so it works
better than and the end is that really
an explanation two issues one is just
the term rarely diffraction doesn't get
very far you have to understand what it
is you have to work through the
equations and you have to understand
that light has the spectrum and so on
and there's a lot more to it than just
that one term so that that's certainly
true I think you're also asking the
question these are these two so-called
explanations of why the sky is blue
you're asking couldn't they both be true
and the difficulty that I have with that
is that they probably can both be true
that's not out of the question after all
we've got these three laws of mechanics
that I put up and when you're dealing
with certain domains all three of them
are make accurate predictions and all
three of them are in that sense useful
theory some are easier to use than
others but yes you can have more than
one scientific theory so but each one
ought to be judged on those on the basis
of its accuracy simplicity and
suggestiveness and so let me just take
it
why do you assume something about me
that wasn't true criteria science
adjustability that were allowing your
pragmatism to be a little bit more
reasonable because you can test some of
the same look at world religions you
know you can test the Christian faith as
to how well that alleviates grace versus
let's say tera vaada Buddhism which is
hideous ting so but I'm wondering
whether there couldn't be some version
of pragmatism in these human areas yes
you could you know specify more country
thing like the criteria for workability
might be that's a lot like I don't have
anything to contribute to it myself
reversely flower
is God a scientific warming from my
perspective is involved in spiritual
practice trying to identify the laws of
God and those laws are that he
identified he used scientific method to
do it
Einstein used scientific method you all
use a scientific method
but is it God the lawmaker behind those
laws and you move into another realm
I know Laplace said you don't need that
assumption and you can drop it but
that's the question maybe I think she
was trying to ask my answer that science
doesn't care if it's beyond the provable
and and this outside and cannot be
measured cannot be tested then science
has nothing to say about it and but the
recent science issue of magazine science
showed that a lot of scientists do care
and that I make this obsession well
things and they have the same spectrum
of emotions the same spectrum that other
people many scientists secretly are
doing I would submit that many
successful people in many different
disciplines have an excess existential
pleasure from doing it which is of that
same nature I love being an engineer
it's the same thing no we have to stop
you very simply we have to Sofia Paul
thank you so much
you